why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we begin our discussion on
Infinity Gauntlet issue number three I
think you guys are really going to enjoy
this comic and the reason why is because
what we'll see taking place over the
course of this are battle formations
preparations for war we're going to be
seeing a plan put together and it won't
be until the end of the comic that we
actually understand the true nature of
this plan but what this is is also so
the last issue where we have talking and
it'll be the last issue before we
actually get into the main discussion
the main conflict that takes place
between Thanos and all of these
superheroes leading up to the end of The
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and what we
see here as The Story begins to pick up
is that we're back with Dr Doom Adam
Warlock the Silver Surfer and Doctor
Strange and Dr Doom is commenting on how
he agrees picking up immediately from
the last discussion that now is the Time
for Action but Adam Warlock says no Adam
Warlock says there are forces at work
here that Dr Doom just doesn't
understand that he just can't possibly
grasp and that rushing into action like
this would almost guarantee certain doom
and so he says that he has a intricate
and a very interweaved plan that's
unfolding here and that the slightest
disturbance could very well lead to the
ruin of all what we also see doctor
strange commenting is saying that he
agrees with uh with Adam Warlock that
they have have to trust him that Dr Doom
that Silver Surfer they have to come to
this understanding that Adam Warlock
knows what he's doing that tremendous
powers are gaining here for this final
confrontation and he more or less
repeats the words of Adam Morlock here
saying that um that premature action
could lead to total Destruction and so
Dr Doom acquiesces Dr Doom says that
it's driving him nuts waiting to take
action but that for the time being he's
willing to uh put this off he's willing
to um go ahead and hold things now from
here we see Adam Warlock saying that
it's time to make
preparations that it's time to go about
the business of uh moving to the towards
the next step of his master plan and so
he calls on Doctor Strange and what we
see doctor strange doing is uh
teleporting Adam Warlock Dr Doom and the
Silver Surfer to The Avengers
headquarters and at The Avengers
headquarters we have She-Hulk Captain
America and Thor and they're trying to
come to an understanding of what's going
on here they're trying to deal again as
a followup to the last video of what's
happened since The Disappearance of
various superheroes but when Adam
Warlock and Dr Doom and Dr Strange and
the Silver Surfer appear the immediate
idea is that doctor strange is keeping
strange company that he is with people
whom he would never normally form an
alliance with but what we see is that
immediately Adam Warlock and Doctor
Strange begin to convince um She-Hulk
Thor and Captain America that the
situation is so
that Dr Doom is not here to fight
against them that Dr Doom is here to
fight with them and so when the question
is asked what the intention is here for
Adam Warlock why it is that he's here
and why it is that such strange
alliances have been formed Adam Warlock
replies by simply saying that they're
raising an army from here we transition
to Black Widow and black widow doesn't
necessarily give us a huge in-depth
discussion here but because Black Widow
is part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I felt it would be relevant to include
her in this disc discussion and all we
really see is that she's one of the
people on the sideline she's kind of in
the background she's uh doing the best
she can to help save lives as a result
of the energy shock wave that had
reached the planet Earth and the
devastation that it it had caused we see
that she's jumping out of a building out
of a burning building saving a baby and
for the most part this is kind of what
we would expect to see with her
character because she doesn't really
have any superpowers she's just more or
less a super spy with all kinds of
gadgets at her disposal but then we
switch and we see that there's a woman
who is falling out of a building who's
hanging on for dear life and black widow
goes with an attempt to try to save her
but the building collapses and crumbles
before Black Widow can get there and so
again this is Jim Starin this is Marvel
injecting a little bit of realism here
and saying that with with stories like
these with Comics like these that not
everybody makes it out the other side
that not everybody survives and so what
we see is that this woman who was
tumbling to her death did in fact die
that she was crushed by the rebble and
the debris uh debris and even if not
necessarily crushed she was certainly
burned to death and the way that we see
see black widow dealing with this I
think is a great Testament to the the
human nature of her character the
difference between her and a lot of
other superheroes that you see in the
Marvel Community where she just can't
accept the fact that it's enough she
just says that it's not enough that that
her best just simply isn't enough here
from here we switch to uh Dr Strange and
Adam Warlock and what we see doctor
strange doing is calling upon
superheroes calling upon various
individuals to gather to uh to bring
their powers with them due to the
necessity of them and their powers with
regards to the upcoming conflict and the
first two people that we see arriving
here are Iron Man and Spider-Man from
here we switch to uh the arrival of new
characters we see of course wolver rain
coming here we see draxx the destroyer
and again draxx the Destroyer serves the
purpose of I guess trying to or being
able to hunt down and ATT track Thanos
no matter where he is in the cosmos but
due to the fact that Adam Warlock has
Silver Surfer on his side and Silver
Surfer has Cosmic awareness it's really
not the ability of draxx to locate
Thanos that they're interested in it's
the sheer raw power that he possesses
that they're interested in who we also
see showing up here is fire lord now
again we haven't done a big discussion
on Fire Lord but firel Lord was one of
the Heralds of galactic and so for the
most part he was one of the individuals
who served the same purpose as the
Silver Surfer the next person we see
showing up is Nova of the new Warriors
and this is due to the fact that Nova is
the only one at this moment who is able
to tap into the full might of the Nova
force and so for him for for Adam
Warlock and Silver Surfer and the uh the
opposing forces Nova is really a
necessity here he's someone they
absolutely need the next person here is
Ney the Submariner and of course of
course n the Submariner has a super
strength although for the most part in
terms of his relation to characters like
draxon Destroyer or even the Incredible
Hulk he's not all that strong but his
military his ability to uh to plan
tactics his military experience and the
conquest that he's had over the course
of his life will definitely be an asset
to this team the next person we see is
Cloak and again all cloak really does
here is serve the purpose of being
someone that can teleport people over
distances now to my knowledge I don't
think marvelous establish the fact that
cloak can teleport people over an
infinite amount of distance and so
they're not really looking for cloak
here to be someone that teleport
everybody all the way to the other side
of the Galaxy to fight Thanos they
simply have him here because he could be
an individual that could teleport groups
of people around or could do uh serve
some kind of purpose or possibly he
could even swallow Thanos entirely from
here we see the remaining members of
this group coming together we see uh
Cyclops of X Factor because remember at
this time the X-Men were a different
group it was giant siiz X-Men and X
Factor was composed of the original
X-Men team and the way it appears to us
here is that uh of the either original
members of the X-Men or the current
members of the X-Men wol rain and uh
Cyclops seem to be the only ones who
were left alive or at the very least the
only ones who were called upon we also
see the Scarlet Witch arriving here to
meet with the vision we see um The
Incredible Hulk being invited but the
Incredible Hulk doesn't actually show up
at first and the reason why the
Incredible Hulk doesn't show up as is
explained to us by Tony Stark is because
the Avengers had previously turned their
back on uh on the Incredible Hulk due to
the fact that much like we saw with the
Illuminati where he was exiled from the
planet Earth The Incredible Hulk was
deemed too dangerous for himself he was
out of control and so the Avengers
hadn't necessarily abandoned him
entirely but they had um more or less
kind of handed him his hat and shunted
him out but what we see um Iron Man and
and Captain America saying here is that
if he's reformed he can be one of the
Avengers again he can come back uh The
Incredible Hulk overhears this and says
that'll be enough for now and so he
joins the group of superheroes who are
coming to fight against the forces of
Thanos and what Adam Warlock tells us
here is that this Army is now complete
and so the individuals that we see that
have arrived here appear to be the only
individuals who were either left or have
been invited to become part of this from
here we see Captain America am speaking
directly to the forces that have
gathered and Captain America says that
everybody is here to fight the forces of
Thanos to fight against Thanos as his
against his Infinity Gauntlet and what
we see Dr Doom saying is that before
Captain America goes any further that
the question has to be asked here is
Adam Warlock the best person to lead
this group Doctor Strange replies by
asking there's no real discussion here
this is pretty much all there is there's
no two ways about it but Dr Doom says
that he's the only person that has the
ruthlessness the cunningness and the
guile to uh lead this group and of
course for the most part everybody is
against him on this Captain America says
no way the Scarlet Witch um uh
Spider-Man Eric Masterson they all say
that this is not the case and so Captain
America replies to Doctor Strange simply
saying that deep down inside uh I'm
sorry Dr Doom he knows that that Adam
warlock's the only one that can really
stop Thanos that Adam Warlock is the
only one that can really lead them to
Victory and so Dr Doom simply acquiesces
again and says okay at this point we see
that um Adam Warlock says that there is
going to be yet another gathering that
these are the only individuals that have
uh showed up here but that he's also
coming together with uh more allies and
when the question is asked what these
allies are uh Adam Warlock simply
replies by saying Cosmic allies
indicating to us that he's also
Gathering the cosmic entities together
as a a force to fight against the power
of of Thanos what we also see is that
Adam Warlock and um the Silver Surfer
travel to the other side to the far
corner of the Galaxy and the reason for
this as we'll pick up is that they
meeting with quazar and the cosmic
entities in order to uh form a team in
order to come together for the purpose
of um bringing everybody together to
fight against the power of Thanos and
when they arrive that's exactly what
they're what we're told what we're told
is that uh Eon or I'm sorry that Epoch
informs um Adam Warlock that all the
cosmic entities had simply been waiting
for him they were simply waiting for him
to arrive and when he does we see that
almost all of them are gathered here now
there are some Cosmic entities that
aren't here but for the most part almost
all of them or the most prominent ones
are we see Kronos we see the Living
Tribunal we see Master order and Lord
Chaos The Stranger and of course this is
a list that we had previously discussed
so we won't go into it too much longer
but two of the most notable members here
that I would like you to pay attention
to are eternity and the Living Tribunal
and the reason why as this explained to
us is because more or less what they're
calling together here is a trial with a
Living Tribunal overseeing and the whole
reason for this is because again the
Living Tribunal exists to ensure the
cosmic balance is in place that no one
force becomes such a threat to its
universe that it could result in the
destruction of that universe or other
universes should it danger spill over
and what we see eternity saying here is
that he is the embodiment of all that is
of everything with in the universe and
that that Thanos attempts to usurp this
position from him um The Living Tribunal
says that he's considered this matter
but that he cannot interfere and the
reason why is because Thanos only
strives to replace eternity as the uh
the embodiment of all reality and that
natural selection is one of the oldest
truths that that the strong replace the
weak and that if eternity isn't strong
enough to oppose someone who wants to
challenge him and take his place then
eternity should perish and the new Force
should take its place and so the Living
Tribunal says that he cannot interfere
that he will not become involved in this
matter and this is a very big issue here
and the reason why is because if the
Living Tribunal had ruled on the side of
Eternity then the Living Tribunal simply
could have arrived at thanos's location
and blinked him out of existence despite
the power that Thanos had or he could
have simply just stripped him of The
Infinity Gauntlet because as we
discussed with our discussion in the on
the Living Tribunal as a leadup to the
Thanos Quest and The Infinity Gauntlet
event we had talked about how during the
uh during the infinity Crusade during
the um the infinity watch storyline that
Adam Warlock had approached uh the uh
Living Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
after seeing the power that Adam Warlock
possessed and the anger that he had
displayed had simply just eliminated all
the power of The Infinity Gauntlet
within that vicinity from here we see
that uh that eternity is more or less
leaving that he's kind of going off on
his own now what why he's doing this and
what he's doing is actually something
that we don't know and we won't see him
again for quite some time but what we
see is Adam Warlock saying that it
doesn't matter that eternity is not here
what he says is that all of them are
here so that they can fight together so
that all these Cosmic entities can
gather and oppose the force of Thanos
but then we see the Watcher saying that
he cannot be counted among these
individuals that will fight against
Thanos that he is a watcher and due to
his Creed he is unable to interfere that
he can simply he can only observe and
record and so we see that the Watcher
leaves from there we see Thanos I'm
sorry we see a Galactus challenging Adam
Warlock Adam Warlock says that he's here
to lead all of them into an attack
against Thanos but Galactus says why
should they follow one such as him into
battle and so what we see is Adam
Warlock saying that he is here for the
purpose of that that he's here for the
the purpose of leading them into the
conflict and that's the only thing
Galactus needs to concern himself about
Galactus says that he does not heed
empty words from uh from Mortals from
people that he considers to be beneath
him and Adam Warlock simply replies by
saying Galactus is a fool from here we
see Galactus attempts to destroy Adam
Warlock that he blast him with a vast
amount of energy Galactus then begins to
talk with his uh his fellow U Cosmic
entities here and simply say that uh
they they've gathered that their forces
should be enough to defeat Thanos but
then we see that Adam Warlock is
actually alive Adam Warlock is on the
helmet of uh of Galactus and asks him
since when it was that Galactus allowed
the uh the his anger and his uh his
wrath to more or less override his
judgment the Galactus is known for being
one of the most logical beings in the
universe and that surely Galactus can
can determine surely he can find here
that the power the entire might of all
these Cosmic entities put together is
still insufficient for defeating Thanos
and so we see that Master order Lord
Chaos and various other Cosmic entities
band together against Galactus and say
that they are siding with Adam Warlock
from here we transitioned back to uh to
Thanos at The Shrine of death and what
we see Thanos saying is that his enemies
are coming for him that his enemies are
going to attempt to destroy him and he
asks mistress death if she will stand by
his side but mistress death again spurns
Thanos and she seems to turn her back on
him and Thanos simply replies by saying
this is exactly as he had expected that
he had diluted himself into believing
that she could ever really care for him
and so he says that being a Supreme
Being means that he has no need to
suffer in a a void of affection that he
does not have to go alone that he does
not have to rule without mistress death
that with all power all things are
possible and so what he does is create a
being named traxia and txia is as he
describes it everything mistress death
is not that she's everything that Thanos
Longs for that she is the love that he
wants from mistress death that she is a
representation of what he considers to
be beautiful and he says that he's
there's really no need here there's no
need for mistress death anymore that
Thanos found has found his one true mate
but what we see is that this isn't true
that Thanos doesn't really believe this
that Thanos is more or less still in
love with the idea of mistress death and
is still angry at the fact that she will
not return his affection from here we
see that Adam Warlock is preparing
forces he's preparing these superheroes
for the roles that they're going to have
to face he says that the battle that's
coming is going to be fierce and it's
going to be awesome and that it may very
well cost the lives of several
superheroes but that that's the price
that they have to pay he says that
doctor strange has conjured Mystic
conduits that are going to lead them to
particular places to particular
locations where they need to be due to
the plan that Adam Warlock has created
in order for this to succeed and that if
any of them deviate from this plan that
it could very well lead to the ruin of
uh of the universe as well as all of the
superheroes who were fighting at this
point in time what we also see is that a
spell has been cast that's going to
allow these uh these forces to breathe
within the depths of space for 60
minutes without any kind of assistance
and this will become very important
because one thing I want you guys to
keep in mind when we get into the uh to
the coming conflict of The Infinity
Gauntlet is that everything that's going
to take place will take place over 60
minutes and we will see when that 60
Minutes ends we'll know when that 60
Minutes comes to an end that that's one
of the things that Marvel will tell us
is that the 60 Minutes is over and so
what he also says here is that doctor
strange is going to be in the background
Doctor Strange is going to going to be
monitoring everything and he's going to
be keeping Adam Warlock aware of what's
going on telepathically from the
perspective of every single superhero at
this point we see that uh Silver Surfer
and um and Adam Warlock leave they
transition or take off to about a
lightyear away from where Thanos is
currently at and the Silver Surfer is a
little angry about this the Silver
Surfer is a little irritated about this
that they're simply standing on the
sidelines that they are off to the side
while everybody else is engaging in the
conflict and Silver Surfer tells us that
he is at full power now he is completely
rejuvenated and that his strength would
be a vast asset to the coming battle to
the various superheroes and Adam Warlock
says that he is right but that his
strength will most be needed when the
time is right and so what he tells the
Silver Surfer is that he simply just
needs to wait but Silver Surfer much
like a lot of very proud superheroes
doesn't want to but he swallows his uh
Pride here and simply says okay and what
Adam Warlock tells us is that Silver
Surfer doesn't truly understand he
doesn't truly comprehend the situation
that Thanos he controls all facets of uh
of time reality space Power the soul and
the mind and that this isn't some kind
of grandiose statement that this is
absolute truth that he's he's totally un
Invincible that he is completely
omnipotent
that that this rhetoric this this
statement isn't just simply rhetoric
that this is this is basically the
definition of Thanos that he record he
he controls all reality he controls all
there is he says that the power of the
allies of the superheroes is less than
nothing to Thanos that they are defeated
before the battle even begins but that
the true purpose of their attack is to
Simply Be a diversion that they are
sacrificial
lands from here we're going to bring
this comic or bring this video to an end
and in the next video we'll pick up with
the oncoming conflict we'll pick up with
the true conflict as we get into all of
these superheroes fighting against the
forces of Thanos with that being said I
will catch you guys later
[Music]
peace
name